[Musique]
bonjour monsieur Scott j'ose espérer que
votre voyage n'a pas été trop
déplaisant en première classe le
directeur de l'hôtel a sollicité le
plaisir de votre
compagnie bienvenue au
continental cette grande institution
fait partie d'une structure très ancien
des plus SAR que je peux bien
faire quose d' j'ign Franky se cache ce
que Franky a
volé est très important pour des gens
d'une dangerosité extrême trouve-le
parce que sinon je mets la puissance de
toute cette institution sur vous
deux c'est pas le genre d'endroit dont
on ser
[Musique]
intact on tue Cormac on va lui ôter la
vie et aussi lui prendre son satané
sanctuaire et tout ce qui va avec tu
veux prendre la direction de tout c hô
comment tu comptes nous convaincre qu'un
type en lavalière est capable d'un coup
pareil c'est un
foulard il est temps pour moi de
déléguer peut-être que l'un de nos
invités serait
[Musique]
libre Sharon vous êtes ici pour vous
venger non je suis ici pour rendre
justice alerte
rouge et c'est
[Musique]
parti tu crois plus que la grande table
c'est tellement
[Musique]
stupide vous saurez le
trouverci c'est mon S tous ces suceurs
de
bit ce que je vous demande n'est pas
facile je vous offre l'opportunité de
décider qui vous voulez
être on cherche le type à la lavalière
je regrette c'est
interdit